welcome to this video playing caspin yah
hear from Brazil let's see let's play
this 95 maybe I knew it should I try
Bishop c5 cord let's try this it's
probably going to lead to chair a
drastic loss but let's let's just try to
have fun IAM the trucks law i only know
that it exerted exists and no yeah that
this is this is a liner but it cannot
really tell if it's any good for for any
site probably queen to g6 this looks
normal they cannot do 95 at the moment
because of f2 being attacked so but now
i wonder it's night before i move
attending Bishop g4 or something or
queen g6 first maybe this first 95 is
also really opening up their farm always
trying to try to get my my bishop but if
i go here if I go Bishop g4 he cannot
play f3 Knight f3 runs into a very
awkward pin like night XD fire 84s may
be possible and if he moves the Queen I
have aged 6 194 maybe I add this is a
very tricky this is very tricky stuff
age six maybe em and I can just let him
take this age 6
aged six now or can I keep this 94 it's
not really that great but h6 takes d
takes and the night has nowhere to go
but he hears f4i he has a look like f430
tritium
hmm f4 is a problem it really is
h6 take c5 i can take h tags night moves
then Bishop f3 may be going for this H
far blockade
while it's totally crazy okay maybe try
this it's that's that's probably not
working at all okay if I take him that's
f4f take H takes f takes but tough to
say is this really bad for me not sure I
was actually thinking of her this now
the night moves and drug-taking looks
strange some night a four and then I was
thinking of Bishop f3 this was my idea
KX 94 with the with an attack maybe no
that looks dangerous the whole idea is
to block the earth porn and maybe i get
if he takes 94 and my ideas rook age 8
and then the h fall but the crazy game
but it could be could be good maybe g
for now or on nite nite 94 Quincy five
I don't know I don't have time to
calculate Queen g5 Queen age seven
Wow
an important tactical motive is no 92
King edge one Queen h2 and made us near
it's not working at the moment though
the check for this discuss maybe h3 is
going H form
I can just play just and queen edge from
ADA hi what the heck I was only seeing
that the bloody sacrifice I can just
play this inmate him I have no idea
resign if this was any good it was very
very funny let's let's shake some of
this out having this hostess was crazy
let's see Bishop g4 and this is in fact
what the computer wants to do in here it
does not give give my move H take g5 if
it wants to take on c5 after which aged
three years the computer choice yeah
this is of course possible I am cause I
was I was concerned about F form
something like this but it I am stupid
the king is on each 7 of course I don't
know but ok let's let's consider what's
this totally crazy or not f three years
the computer hmm I see f3 yeah ok I
didn't consider that one and now 94 this
is not given so maybe it's not working
Queen III is right we can check this out
and this is very very dangerous yes and
winning right let's it's been a night f3
and this attacking idea he he is
completely cut the whole Queen side is
cut from the action and he is getting
getting checkmated so I cannot take it
here and 94 95 seems to be best and now
it says why this winning plus 2 okay so
around here there should be win Knight
c3 ok Knight c3 looks very good yes
cover c2
yeah 11 problem is that something like
this is simply not leading to anything I
mean I would love to play this with made
on on h1 but that's just g7 hanging and
I'm losing all pieces so this was a
reputation just Knight c3 back yeah this
this now this now is winning funny but
this this is a mate Jack this is a maid
yeah it's just the better move out of
course h3 Queen a tree ah this is this
is the checkmate point of course yeah
okay this this was also a mid here I was
thinking the check and then go from go
from them I I have a strong move here
Bishop g4 is winning and this is also
interesting with the idea to play no
chief form this is in fact very strong
the idea is Nyjah phone no it's not
quite clear what white should do him ok
this is this is just leading to a
checkmate checkmate so I'm winning and
winning here anyway yeah he had spoiled
it with c3 it seems he must play Knight
c3 to cover the all-important square
here yeah what it creates a game this is
a funny line it's it's not something you
maybe want to yeah bet your whole money
on but it's interesting to play it at
one point or another to get some fun ok
thanks for watching